and uh so when you're directly behind
someone if they're looking at their
phone it looks like schwarzenegger's
song it's like you're looking it does
it's like you're looking at his phone oh
because i'm right between right now if
you're on a plane you're on your phone
i'm looking oh for sure i'm looking
forward sure i've read some [ __ ] you
know he's going to the instagram dms and
he goes to the message request and it's
just
broad city i mean there's just so many
girls in there and he's just like man
this guy's got him well you know what i
was doing i realized somebody was doing
that to me i was looking up i i typed in
black studs or something like that
because i was sending black dudes i was
taking pictures too
because i was i'm going to throw it with
deleon
yeah they were just talking about stuff
and i just sent them like i was like
happy monday guys and i sent them this
[ __ ] really good looking black guy
someone saw it just well i was sending i
was i googled a bunch brian googled our
blacks allowed in restaurants yeah old
school yeah yeah he's like well michael
are they allowed in the front of the
plane because he's in the front
door is this legal my fiance my fiance
also like dated black dudes like
athletes in college so that turns you
off yeah i never let her down
by rodney hey hey hold on dude don't go
there like i said racism in me i
send her pictures of a guy like that
like a really good looking dude i go i
go i'm sitting next to this guy and he
likes to swing
she's like you're such a god damn it so
she's like i got black she's cool about
her or she does she get annoyed she's
the best she's the [ __ ] best yeah but
but um i literally do that to different
people but i realized that the guy
behind me was looking i could see the
words but you know there's a cover you
can put over your phone where i need to
blurry and like
i need that i need that because i know
yeah yeah
i am snoopy mcgee you're snoopy